>> Neil: YOU KNOW, IT'S ONE
THING IF YOU'RE A RETAILER AND
NOT AS MANY CUSTOMERS ARE
BUYING.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN MANY ARE JUST
STEAL SOMETHING THE WALL
MA
OUTLINING A PROBLEM THAT HE
MIGHT HAVE TO CLOSE STORES AND
HIKE PRICES TO COMPENSATE.
ALL OF THIS WHEN A STORE IN
FRESNO, WALMART HAS BEEFED UP
SECURITY TO DEAL WITH THAT
RAMPANT CRIME.
LET'S GO TO GIANNO CALDWELL ON
THIS.
PODCAST HOST AND MY FRIEND, THE
LATTERS COUNTS THE MOST TO ME.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I HAVE TO TELL YOU, FOR THOSE
THAT BELIEVE THAT LEGITIMATE
PROTESTS AFTER GEORGE FLOYD THAT
SAID YEAH, YOU CAN GO RIOT, YOU
CAN GO LOOT.
FOR THOSE THAT BELIEVE IN HAVING
LACKS POLICY ON THE CRIMINAL
FRONT GOING FROM $450 IN
CALIFORNIA TO $900 YOU CAN STEAL
UP TO THIS MUCH, YOU WON'T BE
PROSECUTED OR HELD.
OF COURSE YOU CAN STEAL US A
MUCH WANT AND COME BACK FOR
MORE.
FOR THOSE FOLKS, WE'RE SEEING
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF THAT.
STORES CLOSING IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
FAMILY MEMBERS NOT BEING ABLE TO
WORK AND PRICING GOING SKY HIGH
NOR THE REST OF US.
THE NATIONAL RETAIL FEDERATION
SHOWING IN 2021, $95 BILLION IN
LOSSES FROM RETAIL THEFT, AN
INCREASE OF 27%, NEIL.
THIS HAS GONE OUT OF CONTROL.
THEY NEED TO CHANGE THE LAWS AND
CREATE GREATER PENALTIES FOR
THOSE DOING THIS BECAUSE IT'S
COSTING EVERY ONE, EVERYONE WHO
IS DOING IT.
IT'S NOT JUST BIG BUSINESSES.
WE'VE SEEN IT IN CHICAGO AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHERE STORES
ARE CLOSING UP, BUSINESSES ARE
CLOSING UP BECAUSE THEY CAN NO
LONGER AFFORD IT.
>> Neil: WHAT IS WILD, GIANNO AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THESE VIDEOS,
THESE ARE NOT SHY BURGLARS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE FOR
THE MOST PART.
SOME OF THEM UNMASKED.
ONE OF THE THINGS I FOUND
INTERESTING HEARING FROM THE CEO
OF WALMART, IT COULD BE THEIR
OWN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE CAMERAS EVERYWHERE.
PEOPLE HAVE SEEN, WHETHER THEY
WORK THERE OR SHOP THERE OR
TRYING TO STEAL STUFF THERE,
THEY DON'T SEEM TO SHOW MUCH
DISCRETION FOR THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT THEY ALL BUT IGNORE.
>> NO.
OFTENTIMES YOU'LL SEE PEOPLE
THAT WEAR THEIR COVID MASK AND
GO IN AND WREAK HAVOC.
THE STORES HAVE BEEN TELLING
THEIR EMPLOYEES, DO NOT STOP
THESE FOLKS.
WE SAW RECENTLY WHERE SOMEONE
ATTEMPTED TO STOP SOMEONE THAT
WAS STEALING AND THEY GOT BADLY
INJURIES.
THIS HAS BECOME SOMETHING THAT I
DON'T THINK MANY PEOPLE EXPECTED
OVER THE COURSE OF COVID WHERE
PEOPLE ARE REALLY GETTING AWAY
WITH CRIMES THAT CAN INCREASE
THE GREATER THINGS.
YOU SEE FOLKS GO IN AND SMASH
ATMs, GOING IN TO JEWELRY
STORES, APPLE STORES.
ALL KINDS OF THINGS.
IT IMPACTS ALL OF US.
THIS ISN'T OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO
STICK IT TO APPLE, THIS
CORPORATION WITH TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
NO, HIGHER PRICES FOR THE REST
OF US AND THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS
NO LONG HAVE JOBS BECAUSE OF
THIS.
>> Neil: SOME COMMUNICAT
TIE
TRYING TO BEEF UP EXTRA SECURITY
TO DEAL WITH THIS SORT OF
THINGS.
IS THAT A FIRST STEP HERE IN
YOUR EYES?
>> YES.
I THINK THAT'S A FIRST STEP IN
THE IMMEDIATE.
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO CHANGE THE
LAWS.
THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
CRIMINALS NO LONGER FEAR
PERSECUTION.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE KEN FOX IN
CHICAGO, GEORGE GASCON IN
LOS ANGELES.
THESE SOFT ON CRIME DAs THAT SAY
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
THEY CREATED POLICIES THAT
BENEFIT CRIMINALS.
CRIMINALS ARE TAKING FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF THESE
PROSECUTORS TO THANK FOR IT.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO IF YOU
WANT TO SEE THINGS CHANGE?
VOTE THOSE PEOPLE OUT AND STOP
VOTING TO GET PROGRESSIVES IN
OFFICE THAT CREATE THE ISSUE FOR
THE REST OF US.
THAT'S WHAT IMPACTS ALL OF US,
NO MATTER IF YOUR A DEMOCRAT,
REPUBLICAN, PROGRESSIVE.
WE'RE ALL BEING IMPACTED BY
HIGHER PRICES.
MEANWHILE, WE STILL HAVE
INFLATIONARY PRICES ON THE RISE
AND SEEMS THAT IT'S GOING TO GET
WORSE.
THAT'S WHAT IS TRAGIC ABOUT THIS
SITUATION.
>> Neil: THANK GOD THERE'S GUYS
LIKE YOU THAT ARE A THORN IN THE
SIDE OF PEOPLE THAT IGNORE THIS.
YOU HAVE FOR VERY PERSONAL
REASONS.